WELCOME TO A BRAND-NEW HOUR OF
CHLOROQUINE, I’M SANDRA SMITH.
>> Eric: THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US, I’M ERIC SHAWN.
THE VIOLENCE IN CITIES LARGE AND
SMALL IS SIMPLY OVERWHELMING.
77 PEOPLE WERE SHOT JUST THIS
WEEKEND IN CHICAGO AND 14 OF
THEM WERE KILLED INCLUDING A
7-YEAR-OLD GIRL AND A
14-YEAR-OLD BOY.
THERE WAS A NIGHTCLUB THE
SHOOTING IN SOUTH CAROLINA THAT
LEFT TWO PEOPLE DEAD, EIGHT
OTHERS WOUNDED.
AND IN ATLANTA AT THE MAYOR IS
SAYING ENOUGH IS ENOUGH AFTER
MORE THAN 20 PEOPLE WERE SHOT.
AMONG THE VICTIMS, AN 8-YEAR-OLD
GIRL KILLED IT RIGHT NEAR THE
WENDY’S WHERE RAYSHARD BROOKS
HAD BEEN SHOT.
>> WE ARE DOING EACH OTHER MORE
HARMED IN ANY POLICE OFFICER ON
THE SPORTS.
WE HAD OVER 75 SHOOTINGS IN THE
CITY OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
WEEKS.
YOU CAN’T BLAME THAT ON APD.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION
FRUSTRATION.
WE AIN’T GOT NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT, WE INNOCENT.
WE DIDN’T MEAN NO HARM.
MY BABY DID ME NO HARM.
>> Sandra: IN NEW YORK CITY AT
LEAST 12 PEOPLE KILLED, AND IN
RESPONSE TO THE PRESIDENT SAYING
THIS IN A TWEET.
THE GOVERNMENT IS WILLING, READY
AND ABLE TO HELP IF ASKED.
KAYLEIGH McENANY, GOOD MORNING
TO YOU AND THANK SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
IT’S HORRIFIC TO SEE WHAT PLAYED
OUT AND SOME OF THESE SEEM MAJOR
U.S. CITIES OVER THE WEEKEND.
DEADLY SHOOTINGS AND STABBINGS
AND CHILDREN INJURED AND IN SOME
CASES, KILLED IN THIS VIOLENCE.
AS A PRESIDENT SEE THE NEED TO
STEP IN AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN
THESE U.S. CITIES OF THE
VIOLENCE?
>> THE PRESIDENT SEES THIS AS
UNACCEPTABLE BUT THE PAIN ON
THAT MOTHER’S FACE IS REALLY
HARD TO WATCH, TO THINK THAT
FIVE CHILDREN WERE KILLED THIS
WEEKEND DOING EVERYTHING EVERY D
BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE IS
HIS DOJ UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP HAS
BEEN AGGRESSIVELY LOOKING AT
PROSECUTIONS.
MORE THAN THAT WITH HAD FEDERAL
PROTECTIVE SERVICES THAT HAVE
BEEN IN THE STATES AS A BACKUP
TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ULTIMATELY IT’S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF STATE
GOVERNORS AND MAYORS WHO HAVE
POLICE POWER TO MAINTAIN THE
STREETS BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN DOING EVERYTHING ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE TO SAY THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND IT’S TIME FOR
THESE DEMOCRAT MAYORS AND
GOVERNORS TO STEP UP BECAUSE NO
MOTHER SNAP TO EXPERIENCE THE
PAIN THAT I JUST SAW ON THAT
MOTHER’S FACE.
>> Eric: ERIC SHAWN HERE IN
NEW YORK.
BASICALLY AGAINST THE POLICE.
WHERE ARE ALL THE DEMONSTRATIONS
OF ALL THESE VICTIMS?
THIS IS BEEN GOING ON IN CHICAGO
FOR YEARS.
THERE’S CARNAGE ON THE STREETS
OF THIS COUNTRY FROM THIS
UNCONTROLLED VIOLENCE WHICH IS
GETTING EVEN WORSE, WHAT DOES
THE PRESIDENT SAY ABOUT THAT?
AND THE OUTRAGE OVER WHAT HAS
HAPPENED.
>> THAT’S A GREAT POINT, WHERE
IS THE OUTRAGE FOR THESE
VICTIMS?
WE HAVE THIS OUTSPOKEN ATTITUDE
AGAINST POLICE TO DEFUND OF THE
POLICE MOVEMENT, 1 BILLION TAKEN
FROM THE POLICE DEPARTMENT IN
NEW YORK.
WHAT YOU SEE WITH AOC AS THAT
DIDN’T GO FAR ENOUGH.
YOU SEE A PULLING BACK OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WE SEEN
THOSE MASS RETIREMENTS IN
NEW YORK THAT ULTIMATELY LEADS
TO THE KIND OF VIOLENCE THAT WE
SEE IN THE STREETS.
THERE WAS AN ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT
FUNDING BEING PULLED FROM
L.A.P.D. AND WE SAW AN INCREASE
IN HOMICIDES, IT WAS OVER 100%
INCREASE.
THERE ARE REAL CONSEQUENCES.
WE NEED OUTRAGE FOR THESE
VICTIMS AND FOR THESE HORRID
INCIDENCES OF VIOLENCE THAT WE
ARE SEEING THAT SHOULD NOT BE
TAKING PLACE IN OUR STREETS.
>> Sandra: I WANT TO MOVE ON
TO THE SPIKE IN CORONAVIRUS
CASES THAT WE ARE SEEING IN OUR
COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS OVER THE
WEEKEND AND IT’S GETTING A LOT
OF HEADLINES.
>> President Trump: WE HAVE
TESTED ALMOST 40 MILLION PEOPLE.
BY SO DOING, WE SHOW CASES.
99% OF WHICH ARE TOTALLY
HARMLESS.
RESULTS THAT NO OTHER COUNTRY
CAN SHOW BECAUSE NO OTHER
COUNTRY IS TESTING THAT WE HAVE,
NOT IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS OR
IN TERMS OF THE QUALITY.
>> Sandra: THAT’S ESPECIALLY
NOT BACKED UP BY STEPHEN HANH,
THE FDA DIRECTOR.
DR. FAUCI IS NO WARNING OF
CORONAVIRUS MUTATIONS THAT CAUSE
ILLNESS TO SPREAD EVEN FASTER.
DOESN’T HELP TO HAVE THE
PRESIDENT TALK ABOUT THIS
DISEASE BEING HARMLESS IN 99% OF
INSTANCES?
>> IF THE PRESIDENT WAS MAKING A
FACTUAL POINT THAT MOST PEOPLE
WILL RECOVER FROM CORONAVIRUS
WHO GETS IT.
A SMALL FRACTION OF PEOPLE FALL
VICTIM TO CORONAVIRUS IN A FATAL
WAY AND THAT’S BECAUSE AS WE
SEE, WE HAVE THERAPEUTIC AND WE
HAVE WAYS TO TREAT THIS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MORTALITY
RATES ACROSS THE WORLD WE ARE
FAR BELOW ITALY, WE ARE BELOW
GERMANY AND BELOW FRANCE AND
IT’S BECAUSE OF THE GREAT WORK
WE PUT IN.
THE PRESIDENT TAKES COVID
SERIOUSLY, BUT -- >> Sandra:
SHOULD WE BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SPIKE IN CASES WE SEEN OVER THE
WEEKEND?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS MONITORING
IT, AND HE BELIEVES THAT WE AS A
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE EQUIPPED
TO HANDLE THOSE FIRES.
WE HAVE A GREAT THERAPEUTICS,
DEXAMETHASONE AND CONVALESCENT
PLASMA, REMDESIVIR WHICH IS USED
TO TREAT THE SPIKES.
>> Sandra: DO YOU FEEL THAT
PEOPLE ARE COMPLACENT?
THERE WAS A RALLY IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
ON WHAT TYPES OF PRECAUTION
SHOULD PEOPLE TAKE?
>> THE CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR.
NOT ONLY WILL WILL WE BE GIVING
MASKS BUT WE WILL RECOMMEND THE
WEARING OF THOSE MASKS.
ONE OTHER NOTE THAT I WOULD PUT
HERE JUST TO GO BACK TO YOUR
OTHER QUESTION WITH REGARD TO
CASES THAT WE ARE SEEING, IT’S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT AT
THE HEIGHT OF COVID-19 IN APRIL,
WE WERE TESTING MORE THAN
160,000 PER DAY.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THESE
FIRES, IT’S WORTH NOTING THAT
WHEN WE TEST AT THE RATE AT
WHICH WE DO WE SEE A GREATER
NUMBER OF CASES.
>> Sandra: THIS IS THE LATEST
ON THE HOSPITALIZATION STATS
SINCE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
NUMBERS AND IN SOME CASES THAT’S
ONE OF THE KEY STATS THAT WE
LOOK AT.
THE OVERALL ACCUMULATIVE
COVID-19 RATE, OBVIOUSLY THOSE
KEY HIGH RISK CATEGORIES ARE
STILL WHAT WE ARE WATCHING THIS
CASES.
DR. FAUCI AND OTHERS, WHO DOES
THE PRESIDENT LISTEN TO THE MOST
RIGHT NOW, KAYLEE, AS WE TRY TO
WORK OUR WAY THROUGH THIS
DISEASE, CONSIDERING THERE IS
STILL SO MUCH THAT WE DON’T KNOW
AND WE HAVE SO MUCH MORE TO
LEARN ABOUT IT?
>> THE PRESIDENT HEARS ADVICE
FROM ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
DOCTORS.
DR. HAHN, DR. FAUCI, DR. BIRCH.
THE TASK FORCE COMES TOGETHER
AND PRESENTS THAT INFORMATION IN
THE PRESIDENT IS REALLY BRIEFED
ON THIS.
WE HAS IN AMERICAN SOCIETY HAVE
STEPPED UP.
WE HAD THE LOWEST MORTALITY
RATES, ONE OF THE LOWEST IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD AND THAT IS BECAUSE
OF AMERICAN INNOVATION.
THAT’S BECAUSE UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE LEFT MIKE
LED THE WAY IN THERAPEUTICS.
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL HAVE
THAT BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
THIS PRESIDENT WHO TEARS DOWN
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS TO PAVE
THE WAY FOR AMERICA TO WORK ITS
WAY THROUGH COVID-19.
>> Eric: WE SAW THE AMAZING
FLYOVER AND CELEBRATION ON
SATURDAY NIGHT.
HERE IS A PRESIDENT SPEAKING
ABOUT WHAT HE SAYS NOW IS
BASICALLY A CULTURE WAR.
SPEAK TO THIS LEFT-WING CULTURAL
REVOLUTION IS DESIGNED TO
OVERTHROW THE
AMERICAN REVOLUTION.
>> President Trump: WE WILL
NEVER LET THEM RIP AMERICA’S
HEROES FROM OUR MONUMENTS OR
FROM OUR HEARTS.
BY TEARING DOWN WASHINGTON INTO
JEFFERSON, THESE RADICALS WOULD
TEAR DOWN THE VERY HERITAGE FOR
WHICH MEN GAVE THEIR LIVES TO
WIN THE CIVIL WAR.
>> Eric: OVER THE WEEKEND, A
STATUE OF CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS
WAS TAKEN DOWN IN BALTIMORE AND
THROWN ON AND THE INNER HARBOR.
THE DEMOCRATIC COUNCIL WANTS TO
TAKE THOMAS JEFFERSON OUT OF THE
CITY COUNCIL AND TAMMY DUCKWORTH
WAS ASKED ABOUT TAKING DOWN
GEORGE WASHINGTON AND SHE
REPLIED ON CNN SHE WOULD BE OPEN
TO HEARING THE ARGUMENT.
WHAT IS THE ADO ABOUT TAKING
DOWN GEORGE WASHINGTON AND SOME
OTHERS?
>> THIS IS ABSOLUTE INSANITY.
AMERICA IS THE GREATEST COUNTRY
ON EARTH.
THIS NATION AND THE BEDROCK OF
FREEDOM HAS DONE MORE FOR THE
WORLD AND FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF
HUMAN HISTORY THAN ANY COUNTRY
ON PLANET EARTH.
THIS IS A GOOD COUNTRY, A
COUNTRY TO BE PROUD OF AND THE
PRESIDENT WILL NEVER APOLOGIZE
FOR WHAT MAKES AMERICA GREAT.
WITH THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING
HERE AND HAS HAD QUITE CLEARLY
IN THE SPEECH, WE ARE NOT
FURTHER RIPPING DOWN MONUMENTS
AND AMERICA STANDS WITH HIM, 71%
ARE AGAINST THE DRIPPING DOWN OF
STATUES AND MONUMENTS AND ARE
QUITE PROUD OF THIS COUNTRY AND
WHAT WE HAVE DONE TO ADVANCE
FREEDOM ACROSS THE WORLD.
>> Eric: JONI ERNST ABOUT A
LOT OF HEADLINES OVER THE
WEEKEND, APPEARING TO DISTANCE
YOURSELF FROM THE PRESIDENT,
TALKING ABOUT BLEMISHES IN OUR
HISTORY AND THE NATION NEEDING
TO COME TOGETHER, BUT
SPECIFICALLY DISTANCING HERSELF
FROM THE PRESIDENT, PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS AND OTHER THINGS.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT THAT THIS MORNING?
>> THE PRESIDENT AGAIN STANDS
FIRMLY AGAINST THE RENAMING OF
OUR BASE.
THIS PRESIDENT STANDS BY AND ARE
GREAT MONUMENTS, MANY OF WHICH
HAVE BEEN DEFACED LIKE
ULYSSES S. GRANT AND GANDHI WHO
IS KNOWN FOR PEACEFUL PROTESTS
AND WAS AN INSPIRATION TO
REVEREND MARTIN LUTHER KING,
THESE MOBS HAVE NOTED IDEOLOGY.
THEY ARE DEFACING ABOLITIONISTS
AND DEFACING WAR MONUMENTS TO
BLACK AMERICANS WHO SERVED IN
THE CIVIL WAR.
THEY HAVE NO RHYME OR REASON OR
IDEOLOGICAL THOUGHTS.
>> Sandra: CONSIDERING THE
STANCE, AS A PRESIDENT CONCERNED
THAT THERE MIGHT BE OTHER
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS LIKE HER
THAT DISTANCE THEMSELVES FROM
THE PRESIDENT’S VIEWS ON THAT?
>> NO BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
KNOWS HE STANDS FIRMLY AND
SQUARELY WITH THE MAJORITY OF
THE AMERICANS.
IT’S UNACCEPTABLE TO PULL DOWN
OUR STATUES AND DEFACED GANDHI
AND SOME OF THE GREAT
ABOLITIONISTS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
EITHER TOPPLED OR TORN DOWN
ACROSS COUNTRY.
>> Sandra: THERE WAS EVEN AT
DESTRUCTION OF A FREDERICK
DOUGLASS STATUE.
ANY UPDATE ON THE GARDEN OF
STATUES?
I WILL POINT OUT THAT THERE IS
THE HALL OF FAME AMERICAN AND
BRONX, NEW YORK, AND THEY HAVE
BUS, 98 OF THEM.
SOME OF THE SAME PEOPLE THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS PROPOSED FOR HIS
GARDEN FOR CELEBRATION.
WHEN DO WE EXPECT THAT TO OPEN
AND WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
>> WE HOPE TO SEE THAT OPEN, AND
THE 60 DAYS TO LOOK INTO THIS,
AND I THINK THE PROSPECT OF
HAVING A GARDEN OF HEROES IS A
GREAT WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT
AMERICA’S STUDENTS KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND HISTORY BY
COMMEMORATING PEOPLE LIKE
MARTIN LUTHER KING JR. AND BETSY
ROSS, SUSAN B. ANTHONY AND THESE
GREAT AMERICAN ICONS WHO MAKE
GREAT STRIDES FOR BLACK
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY, AND
FOR WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO REMEMBERING THAT, KNOWING OUR
HISTORY AND STILL AWAITING OUR
HEROES IS ONE GOAL THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD IN COMPLETING THIS
GARDEN.
>> Sandra: I WANT TO FINISH UP
BY ASKING YOU ABOUT A RECENT
TWEET, GOING BACK TO BOB WALLACE
AND WHAT THE INVESTIGATION OF
WHAT HE AND OTHERS AT THE TIME
THOUGHT IT WAS A NOOSE.
IF THE INVESTIGATION REVEALED IT
WAS A PULL ROPE FOR THE GARAGE
THAT HAD BEEN IN PREVIOUS
PICTURES.
THE PRESIDENT IS BRINGING IT
BACK IN A BRAND-NEW TWEET.
AS BUBBA WALLACE APOLOGIZE TO
ALL THOSE GREAT NASCAR LEADERS
AND OFFICIALS WHO CAME TO BE BY
HIS SIDE ONLY TO FIND OUT THAT
THIS WAS ANOTHER HOAX?
THAT AND FLY DIVISION HAS CAUSED
THE LOWEST RATINGS EVER.
THIS WAS NEVER DETERMINED IT TO
A HOAX, KAYLEE.
IS IT HELPFUL FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO BRING THAT BACK UP,
CONSIDERING THIS IS SOMETHING
OBVIOUSLY THAT THE FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION WEIGHED IN ON?
HE HAS DONE MANY INTERVIEWS
SINCE THEN BUT TO DETERMINE IT A
HOAX IN A NEW TWEET?
>> NASCAR WOULD NOTE, THEIR
STATEMENT SAYS THAT THIS GARAGE
PULL ROPE WITH STAIRS SINCE LAST
FALL AND THEY ALSO SAID
DEFINITIVELY, THE FBI
INVESTIGATION DETERMINED THAT
THERE WAS NO HATE CRIME.
THE PRESIDENT IS MAKING A
BROADER POINT THAT JUDGING
BEFORE THE FACTS ARE OUT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
WE SAW IT WITH THE COVINGTON
KIDS AND JUST A SMALL OUT JUST A
>> Sandra: PEOPLE WILL BE
QUICK TO POINT OUT THAT THIS
COMPARISON IS NOT FAIR.
>> THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION DOES NOT STAND BY
THAT ASSESSMENT.
THE PRESIDENT IS MERELY POINTING
OUT THAT WE HAVE TO LET THE
FACTS COME OUT BEFORE WE RUSH TO
JUDGMENT AND THERE WAS NO
HATE CRIME COMMITTED AGAINST
BUBBA WALLACE AS DETERMINED BY
THE FBI AND AS NOTED IN A NASCAR